MARK: HELLO AMERICA, I AM
MARK LEVIN, THIS IS "LIFE,
LIBERTY AND LEVIN."
OVER 40 YEARS AGO I WAS A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
OUTSIDE OF PHILADELPHIA.
I REMEMBER WE HAD SOME
RUCKUS MEETINGS THEN, WE
DIDN'T CALL IN FBI OR
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABSURD, AS
IT IS TODAY, BUT TODAY'S
ISSUES ARE MORE IMPORTANT.
HAVE YOU WONDERED WHY
DEMOCRAT DON'T DENOUNCE
CRITICAL RACE THEORY?
IT IS BIGOTRY RACISM.
IT WAS BORN OUT OF 1970S,
FOUNDING FATHER DERRICK
BELL, A MARXIST LAW
PROFESSOR AT HARVARD, HE WAS
CONSIDERED FRINGE BACK THEN,
AND HIS SCHOLARSHIP
CONSIDERED SHODDY, IT HAS
SPREAD LIKE POWS POISON
THROUGH OUR UNIVERSITIES,
NOW IT IS SPREAD THROUGH
MIDDLE SCHOOLS, HIGH SCHOOLS
AND ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS,
WE'RE TOLD TO SIT DOWN AND
SHUT UP AND JUST TAKE IT.
THESE ISSUES AFFECT EVERY
CORNER OF UNITED STATES
EVERY CLASSROOM.
CRITICAL RACE THEORY HAS
BEEN EMBRACED BY THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY, MEDIA, JOE
BIDEN WHO HAS.
IF WE DON'T PUT AN END TO
THIS, WE'LL DESTROY THE
SOCIETY, THIS COUNTRY,
DESTROY THE FAMILY,
FAITH AND THE
REST, IT IS MARXISM.
IT WAS BORN AT HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL, BY DERRICK BELL, HE
WAS A MARXIST, IT IS PUSHED
BY MARXISTS THIS IS FOUNDING
IDEOLOGY BEHIND THIS THEORY,
THINK ABOUT IT.
IF YOU ARE A CERTAIN RACE
YOU ARE OPRESSED, EVEN IF
YOU ARE NOT IN YOUR OWN LIFE
YOU ARE OPRESSED.
IF YOU ARE ANOTHER RACE ARE
AN OPRESSURE.
YOU ARE WHITE.
THAT IS HOW THIS WORKS.
WHITE VERSUS ALL MINORITIES,
THIS IS THE AMERICANIZATION
OF MARXISM.
IT IS PER -- WE HAVE TWO
GREAT GUESTS, REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE FOR GOVERNOR IN
VIRGINIA GLENN YOUNGKIN AND
ALSO LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
CANDIDATE IN VIRGINIA
WINSTON SEARS, WE WANT TO
TALK TO THEM BUT FIRST A
QUICK REDO, WE HAD LETTER
FROM NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION SEPTEMBER 29,
2021.
AN INSIDE JOB.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THEY CONSPIRED TO GO AFTER
PARENTS.
PARENTS, GRANDPARENTS TAX
PAYERS, CITIZENS WHO HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT CRITICAL RACE
THEORY AND THE TRANSGENDER
MOVEMENT AND OTHER THINGS
GOING ON IN OUR SCHOOLS TO
INDOCTRINATE OUR CHILDREN.
IN PART YOU RECALL THAT
LETTER SAID, THESE ACTS OF
MALICE, VIOLENCE AND THREATS
AGAIN PUBLIC SCHOOL
OFFICIALS BY PARENTS, HAVE
INCREASES --
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THIS
PHONY LETTER WAS SENTIMENT
THE WOMAN WHO SIGNED IT GOT
A JOB TWO DAYS LATER IN
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IN
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT.
, ARE YOU AWAY OF THAT?
THEY COORDINATED WE BELIEVE
PROTHE TEACHERS UNIONS AND
OTHERS, 5 DAYS LATER, THE
MEMO APPEARS SIGNED BY
GARLAND, WE TALKED ABOUT
HERE FIRST ON "LIFE, LIBERTY
AND LEVIN."
IN SHORT MEMO, IT SAYS:
>> WHEN GARLAND WAS ASKED
ABOUT THIS, HE COULD NOT
POINT TO THE EXAMPLES OF
RISE IN CRIMINAL CONDUCT
AGAIN SCHOOL PERSONNEL.
SAID I'M DIRECTING FBI
WORKING WITH EACH U.S.
ATTORNEY TO CONVENE MEETINGS
WITH LEADERS.
IN EACH DISTRICT.
THESE MEETINGS
DISCUSS STRATEGIES --
>> THEY HAVE NO EXAMPLES OF
VIOLENCE, NO PATTERN OF
VIOLENCE AS WE DISCUSS, NOW
WE KNOW SCOTT SMITH, USED
BY NATIONAL MEDIA BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE AND OTHERS, AS
AN EXAMPLE OF VIOLENCE, HE
WAS NOT VIOLENT IN THE
LEAST, VIOLENCE WAS DONE TO
HIM, HIS FAMILY, HIS
DAUGHTER OF RAPED IN THE
GIRL A ROOM AT STONE BRIDGE
HIGH SCHOOL IN VIRGINIA,
RAPED, IT WAS COVERED UP.
THEY LIED.
THAT BOY WAS SENT TO ANOTHER
HIGH SCHOOL WHERE HE RAPED
AGAIN.
AND FOUND GUILTY SINCE BY A
JUVENILE COURT.
WE NOW HAVE MORE INFORMATION
THAT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN LADEN COUNTY, WAS
APPALLED BY WHAT THE SCHOOL
BOARD WAS DOING.
NEW DOCUMENTS OBTAINED BY
FOX NEWS SHED LIGHT ON
APPARENT CONFLICT AND
FRUSTRATION, LADEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAD WITH SCHOOL
BOARD.
E-MAIL SHOW LADEN COUNTY
SHERIFF OFFICE REJECTING
WHAT IS SAID WERE SECURITY
MEASURES, INCLUDING AN
EXPLOSIVE SWEEP IN
UNDERCOVER PRESENT BY
SUPERINTENDENT FOR FUTURE
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS, IN
AUGUST 6 E-MAIL,
SUPERINTENDENT REQUESTED THE
-- LADEN COUNTY
DEPUTIES, A SPECIAL
OPERATION TEAM TO STAND BIA.
NOW THE LOUDOUN COUNTY
SHERIFF IS A GOOD MAN, HE
SAID, STICK IT.
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT TO THE
PEOPLE OF LOUDOUN COUNTY,
NOT TO PARENTS THERE IS NO
JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS.
THE FEDS STILL HAVE THAT
MEMO OUT WHERE THEY WANT TO
TARGET LOUDOUN COUNTY, EVERY
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE
PARENTS DARE TO SPEAK OUT
WITH A DOMESTIC TERRORISM
HOT LINE.
A TEACHER, A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER, SAYS OH, I FEEL
THREATENED.
THEY CALL, AND FBI SHOWS UP
THAT IS OUTRAGEOUS, THESE
ARE PARENTS WHO WANT A
QUALITY EDUCATION.
KNOWN FOR SCHOOL SYSTEM, AND
SCHOOL S.A.T. AND OTHER
RESULTS ARE GOING DOWN, THEY
ARE PLUMMETING BECAUSE OF
THE IDEOLOGICAL AGENDA OF
AMERICAN MARXIST AND
DEMOCRAT PARTY AND TEACHERS
UNION AND YOU HAVE PARENTS
HERE WHO ARE STANDING UP,
DEMOCRATS, INDEPENDENTS AND
REPUBLICANS, MEANWHILE, AT A
HEARING, SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE DICK DURBIN, WHAT
DOES HE SAY ABOUT THESE
PARENTS?
THESE ARE NOT ROUTINE
PEOPLE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTING OUT THEIR FEELINGS IN
A VIOLENT MANNER OVER AND
OVER, THE SAME PEOPLE WE SEE
ON AIRPLANES AND OTHER
PLACES, SOME OF WHOM WE SAW
HERE JANUARY 6?
REALLY SENATOR, WHAT ABOUT
THE PEOPLE WITH BLACK LIVES
MATTER AND ANTIFA?
ARE THEY PUSHING CRITICAL
RACE THEORY THEORY IDEOLOGY,
HOW COME YOU NEVER DENOUNCE
BLACK LIVES MATTER OR
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, EVER
WHY.
BARACK OBAMA MUST LEAVE ONE
OF HIS MANSIONS OR A YACHT
TO FLY INTO LOUDOUN COUNTY
FOR A FEW HOURS TO HELP HIS
FRIEND TERRY MCCAULIFFE.
TERRY MCCAULIFFE OPPOSE
POLICIES ARE IDENTICAL TO
JOE BIDEN WHEN INFLATION OR
TAXES.
WHETHER IT IS IMMIGRATION OR
FOR.
BARACK OBAMA BREITBART
WRITES:  CALLS OUTCRY PHONY,
COVERED UP TRUMPED-UP
CULTURE WARS.
WE DON'T HAVE TIME, THIS IS
OBAMA.
RESPONSE TO THAT WAS QUICK
AND HARSH, THAT BARACK OBAMA
IS IGNORING COVERING UP RAPE
THAT TOOK PLACE IN LOUDOUN
COUNTY PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM,
AND THERE IS MORE OF THIS
UNDER INVESTIGATION NOW.
OBAMA MAKES THIS STATEMENT,
NOW A JUDGE FOUND THIS MAN,
THIS KID, SO-CALLED, GUILTY
OF RAPE.
BUT OBAMA CAM COMES IN
THEY DON'T CARED ABOUT THE
RAPE VICTIM OR EDUCATION OF
CHILDREN OR CONCERNS OF THE
PARENTS, HOW DO WE KNOW THAT
TERRY MCCAULIFFE HAS SAID
RADICAL RACISTS IDEAD ON GEE
IDEOLOGY IS A RACISTS DOG
WHISTLE.
PARENTS AND THE REST OF US
HAVE BEEN WATCHING, WHEN
THERE WAS VIRTUAL EDUCATION,
AND WE SAW WHAT THE KIDS
WERE TAUGHT.
MAKING MILLIONS WRITING
BOOKS THAT ARE USED THIS
CLASSROOMS, AND WRITING
SOFTWARE USED IN THE
CLASSROOMS, HERE WE HAVE
VIRGINIA'S DEPUTY OF
EDUCATION PRO -- DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION PROMOTING A
BOOK, SAYING TEACHERS MUST
EMBRACES THEORIES SUCH AS
CRITICAL RACE THEORY,
DESPITE PACK THAT TERRY
MCCAULIFFE SAID WE DON'T DO
THAT IN VIRGINIA.
AND INCLUDES BOOKS BY ANTIS
ANTI-- SHE WRITES TEACHERS
MUST EMBRACE
THEORIES.
AND WROTE WE WANT TO DO MORE
THAN SURVIVE, IT GOES ON.
TERRY MCCAULIFFE SAID IT IS
A DOG WHISTLE.
YOU KNOW THERE IS A REASON
THAT FORMER GOVERNMENT OF
VIRGINIA, AFRICAN-AMERICAN
FIRST AFRICAN-AMERICAN
GOVERNOR, AND SO FAR LAST
DOUGLAS WILDER HAS CONDEMNED
TERRY MCCAULIFFE.
HE SAID YOU RAN IN A
DEMOCRAT PRIMARY AGAINST TWO
BLACK WOMEN AND DEFEATED
THEM.
YOU DID ALMOST NOTHING AS
GOVERNOR FOR THE
BLACK COMMUNITY, AND DON
CONDEMNED FOR KAMALA HARRIS
TOR SWINGING TO VIRGINIA
WITH HER VIDEOS, YOU HAVE
EXPOSED OVER 300 BLACK
CHURCHES TO TALK AUDITS,
PERHAPS PULLING THEIR CHAIR
TAL FOUNDATION, HE IS
CONDEMNED THEM BOTH, HE
SAID, IT IS NOT ABOUT THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
IT IS ABOUT THE CITIZENS OF
VIRGINIA, INCLUDING
BLACK CITIZENS OF
VIRGINIA, THEY HAVE LOST
CONNECTION ABOUT THEM.
DEMOCRAT PARTY
EM-- EMBRACES BUT CELEBRATES
AND PROMOTES IT.
WH